I've heard you talk in interviews
especially lately because of 80 for
Brady and these these a bunch of your
recent uh films that comedy came too
late first of all you're hilariously
funny I thought cataloo you're that's a
that's a fantastic comedy that was your
I think first big hit and you were funny
then what made you why was it a surprise
to you later on that you were if
somebody is writing funny dialogue for
me and the setup is funny I can be funny
yeah I'm not natural I'm naturally kind
of depressed my dad my mom suffered from
depression but I have spent 80 years
trying to get over that and you know
I've really worked hard to not be a
depressed person but I'm basically
Earnest you know I can tell when I'm
sitting with Lily you know somebody will
come up and ask us a question and she
will automatically answer something that
is hysterical yeah and I just I'm gonna
answer the question
you know who really helped me Ted
spending 10 years with Ted who is
hysterical Ted Turner's a funny man oh
my God he is funny and outrageous yeah
and I saw it's okay to be outrageous
yeah and that really helped me that's
yeah he seems to not care what anybody
else is like a sieve it just all comes
out but he had his take on life is just
like lilies is inherently funny I just
think it's unfair to you to say I don't
think I'm uh gifted in comedy because
when I'm sitting next to Lily Tomlin
it's you're you're you're grading
yourself on this crazy scale yes Lily
Tomlin is one of the greatest the
stratosphere yeah she's in the
stratosphere but you walked into our
podcast building and had the room
laughing right away and so yeah it's
because of Ted Turner no it is okay all
right right I didn't know that yeah okay
thank you Mr Turner
We for years on my show when I moved to
Turner Network because it was Turner
Network we had a very talented actor
from Saturday Night Live portrayed Ted
Turner he'd come in to give me advice on
a stuffed Buffalo
Bills yeah yeah I just didn't want to I
didn't want Turner to go after Will
Forte I want him just coming after me no
I'm kidding uh but um yeah he would come
in and go yeah and give me all this
advice and the crowd always loved it and
I thought Someday I'm gonna walk out in
the parking lot and Ted Turner is going
to pistol whip me
and then right off on his stuffed
Buffalo
um he has the largest private herd of
buffalo in the world he brought back the
Bison actually that's the way that
they're called I don't see how I compete
with these other men that you've had in
your life I don't think you do okay all
right thanks guys
sorry except defeat gracefully yeah
nobody could compete with Ted oh yeah
yeah it sounds like it I thought the
Buffalo thing was a bit but it's not no
he has that's incredible he's been
obsessed with bison and he's grown a
herd he had ten thousand when I married
him and now you know many fif he buys
property he's got a couple of million
acres in order to grow his bison herd
it's amazing
I'd heard that yeah you heard that I
heard about the her you heard about the
her I heard about the herd yes yes yeah
that's uh that's a well-known fact I'm
sorry I'm just I don't know anything he
has two million acres and he has gone
about bringing back endangered not just
mammals species but insects and plants
biologists live on all his properties
and they bring back species it's amazing
what he's done because the Buffalo was
more or less extinct yeah and then I
don't know how many heads of Buffalo
there are in the U.S now but the fact
that you can you looked at me like I
don't know because you're always
weighing in with these facts oh
Eduardo's looking it up that's fantastic
feed it to me Eduardo like I knew yeah
what a waste of our time
I know so what's next because you are a
real inspiration I'm going to the gulf
Louisiana and Texas which is kind of the
ground zero for the climate crisis the
Biden Administration has permitted two
dozen new gas terminals
in in places where people are dying from
cancer and heart disease and lung
disease because of the proximity of
petrochemical plants and and you know
there's even a place called cancer alley
in Louisiana but there's all these new
efforts to drill and Frack more okay and
this is a No-No science is very clear we
can't completely do away with fossil
fuels yet but we can gradually phase
them out but we have to stop any new
Drilling and fracking and we don't need
new Drilling and fracking except to get
those guys richer than they already are
right we don't need to do that anymore
and we have to stop the Biden
Administration from doing this so I'm
going to try to go there with fire drill
Fridays and interview and film people
who are dealing with this on the ground
and then you know build it up as an
issue can I ask you how many times
you've been arrested do you know I think
seven that's not a lot Martin Sheen's
been arrested 70 times
me some of that was for activism
he's always punching people for no
reason and no no not the son the father
you're right you're right you're right
Charlie for a second yeah but Charlie's
okay now yeah he's doing fine yeah he's
doing fine well this has been uh we've
been doing this how long have we been
doing this podcast oh four years five
years almost five this is a huge
highlight for me
absolute for me too this uh boy just I'm
really Blown Away we were all so excited
that you were coming here today and
you've been a big part of my life I mean
I adore your work and uh and then you
walk in today and you are stunning you
are so beautiful and so funny and so
smart well I like your I'd like your
people they need to work on me because I
you know you're doing just fine we'll
work it out yeah I gotta do it maybe I
should uh release an exercise video oh
yes please
just me getting up
yeah I love to see that yeah yeah okay
well that's not gonna happen Jane thank
you so much for doing this I ever did a
new video would you do it with me yes I
would okay yes I would to take you off
on it yes I will find a very clingy
unitard yes
little town Gorly okay of course yeah it
will hurt your sales tremendously yeah
but uh we'll get somebody you're very
popular well thank you
Jane thank you so much thank you I
appreciate you having me on Wow goodbye
to all your listeners
janepack.com is how you can join me in
my climate work chainpack.com do that
now